and the Oscar goes to parasite parasite
Paul joon-ho Hong jinho
it was a historic moment parasite is the
first non-english language movie to win
a Best Picture Oscar it also won the
Best Original Screenplay which I believe
is the main reason for the immense
international success of the movie
praises aside what made parasite the
Best Original Screenplay this is the big
question that many screenwriters all
over the world are asking themselves
daily how do I make my screenplay stand
out from the rest well you came to the
right channel and you're watching the
best possible video because parasite is
the perfect example to show you which
are the elements of a truly unique
outstanding screenplay and in the next
couple of videos on this channel
we will review those elements one by one
in this first video let's start with the
most remarkable and innovative element
of the parasite script that makes all
its other elements come to life and make
the film grow tip number one how to
effectively mix genres parasite is a
film that mixes genres of satirical
comedies neo-realist dramas high-wire
thrillers unnerving horror and even
elements of disaster spectacles in the
first half of the film we are watching
two black comedy as the pool Kim's
family manages to infiltrate in the
wealthy parks family one by one as their
employees then on page 71 of 141 pages
of the script exactly at the midpoint
the bell rings
[Music]
now it gets denser who will it be
welcome to the thriller everything
starts to accelerate suddenly the
basement shows up and we bump into
horror movie scenes when Kim's sneak out
of the house they ran into a big storm
and find out the home is flooded and we
get elements of a disaster movie the
film culminates with the tragic birthday
party in reaching its highest point with
drama and tragedy
so parasite goes from funny to
unsettling to deeply heartbreaking in
segments masterfully and seamlessly
combined together mixing genres has a
very special purpose in parasite which
is to create the desired audience's
emotions in every segment of the movie
in the first part we laugh at the
creativity of Kim's infiltration and we
start liking them then in the always
problematic act - it actually already
starts happening with suspense conflict
and dramatic irony and we become totally
immersed in the movie then the flood
comes and we feel sorry for the Kim's
since now we already like them thanks to
the setup in the first act and in the
final act our emotions reach a pinnacle
when we see shocking dramatic moments
immersed in meaning and you leave the
movie theater amazed of what we just saw
and then thinking about the movie for
the next couple of days this is the
effect that every screenwriter should
strive for to achieve with their readers
and their audiences I'm sure that after
the success of parasite now there will
be a lot of screenwriters trying out
this approach of mixing genres which we
definitely should try if it feels right
to you however be careful of two things
first let every genre be there for a
reason and that is to elicit certain
emotions in the audience and to
establish the pace and the structure of
the script and second if you do mix
onerous then be careful that other
screenplay elements are in unity
throughout the movie you see if you mix
onerous you cannot also mix other
elements of the screenplay because you
will create a big mess or in other words
you can break one or two screenwriting
principles but not all of them in the
same screenplay as we can learn from
parasite what it makes is yarn
the main characters in the film stay the
same the main location stays the same
and most importantly the theme of the
movie stays the same and the theme of
parasite and its clever use of the title
will be the topic of our next video so
subscribe to our channel if you don't
want to miss it also go to our patreon
page for more content where we share
extra tips from Goodfellas and pulp
fiction that we don't share anywhere
else keep writing and see you next week
with a new video from parasite
you